[Musique]
au droit à l'information et à la
prévention voilà l'une des priorités du
département de La Réunion il l'a encore
démontré ce mercredi 16 novembre en
lançant son premier forum territorialisé
de l'action sociale et de l'insertion
qui se tenait sur la place du marché
forain de Sainte-Suzanne de 9h à 15h
cette manifestation s'inscrit dans une
démarche plus globale d'aller vers les
publics vulnérables et isolés le
département montre toujours
l'intérêt d'arriver vers la population
puisque notre population est en
souffrance continuellement à travers
beaucoup de difficultés il y a des
mesures oui mais comment j'y vais
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire donc ils sont
aussi dans la méconnaissance et ses
rencontres du permettront justement
d'avoir un éclairage surtout sur leur
ambition à eux et nous aussi voir
comment on les accompagne au mieux
lorsqu'on regarde le contexte économique
et social actuellement on vit dans un
contexte très et par rapport à cela le
Conseil départemental a mis en place un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui répond
aussi à la demande du public la plus
vulnérable et
l'importance au niveau de la proximité
de venir ici à saint-sules pour relayer
tous ces dispositifs tous ces
informations apportées au niveau de la
population de lui dire tout ce qu'ils
ont droit réalisé en partenariat avec la
ville de Sainte-Suzanne la Mission
Locale Nord la CGSS la CAF et les CCAS
de Sainte-Suzanne Saint-Denis et
Sainte-Marie ce forum propose aux
visiteurs des stands d'information mais
aussi une diversité d'ateliers et
d'animation pour les jeunes et les moins
jeunes on retrouvera donc les centres de
l'action sociale de Saint-Denis
Sainte-Marie de Sainte-Suzanne les
services du département au niveau du
social de l'association du sport et de
la culture la CGSS le SIAO donc tout ce
qui concerne l'hébergement d'urgence
dans différentes compétences se retrouve
les notes fameuse camarade des droits
qui vient aussi présenter l'outil et qui
est un outil de proximité et qui donne
du sens aussi à ce forum qui est de dire
qu'on est dans l'allée vera
mais il y a de nous aussi vu que ici
on a un numéro 115 ou c'est de la besoin
d'aide les employeur il y en a pour rien
il y a de banane trouve Volti formation
et tout et il y a dans le Banana après
oui il a deux trois stands intéressants
pour moi
ce forum territorialisé de l'action
sociale et de l'insertion à
Sainte-Suzanne et le premier à la
Réunion mais pas le dernier il se
déplacera aux quatre coins de l'île dans
les prochaines semaines à commencer par
brapanon le 29 novembre et trois bassins
le 9 décembre prochain
[Musique]